barrett
[Music]
if i hear from you again i should inform
the police to understand
that's absolutely final
what thread of strange emotion puts this
brilliantly successful barrister on the
wrong
side of the law well if you dig this
over it could anyone hell of a scandal
and it wouldn't only be you came down
fear is the oxygen of blackmail
barrett was paying others find me one
what crime links him with this
frightened boy on a building site
and why is he afraid why do some
people help him some people turn away in
disgust
why can't he stick with his own sword
you can come home frank jeffries when
you've got rid of him
what sinister shadow from the past now
falls between
husband and wife
[Applause]
when we were married we had no secrets
from each other
i made you a promise then i haven't
broken that promise if that's what you
mean
what secret held these men prisoner in a
tangled web of tyranny and terror
i think we'll have a little privacy
[Music]
what crime linked an aging hairdresser
and a famous star of the theater
this is and i may be mistaken but
do you ever receive an envelope like
that containing a demand for money
they are all victims victims
of what look how he's behaving now
what's happened to his integrity
melts to become a qc lord eventually a
judgey
is he going to sit on the bench knowing
that he himself has covered up a serious
crime
they're going to call me filthy names my
friends are going to lower their eyes
and my enemies say they always guessed
i don't want you a part of that roman
holiday i love you too deeply for that
[Music]
you